in a lab in nottingham they're
developing a vaccine for the new world
of mutating viruses
a covid jab with a double punch against
variants that reduce the effectiveness
of
other vaccines
it's based on the same spike protein as
all the others
but adds another target from the virus
called the n-protein
that evolves far more slowly the
advantage of also having the n-protein
then there is we would still have that
immunity even if the spike is is
mutating
it's that double protection you get it's
like an insurance policy
indeed that's exactly what it is it just
doubles the chances that you win over
the virus
the vaccine is already being made by
cobra biologics
in a room so sterile that these pictures
had to be filmed for us with strict
precautions
tests on animals show it triggers high
levels of antibodies
as well as a strong t cell response
another
critical part of the immune system
clinical trials are due to start within
weeks
and they're welcomed by independent
scientists
our lab and many other labs have
produced very strong evidence
that the immune system sees many
different parts
of the virus and makes great responses
in our assays to this nuclear protein
that she's looking at
and what we don't know until we look is
is how much extra that brings to the
party and
um you know good on her for looking
because we don't look we'll never know
some vaccine makers are simply updating
their jabs against the shifting virus
others planning to add genetic material
from lots of different
variants but all the mutations in the
spike protein are about the virus trying
to find the best
shape for picking the lock that allows
it into human cells
and scientists can predict what that
perfect key would look like
we can almost get ahead of the virus by
saying we know where you're going with
this
we can see where the optimum fit is
going to be
we can predict what that looks like and
we can start to think about making a
vaccine
for that most fit form of the virus
which will eventually come to dominate
coming up that's just a hypothesis for
now but there is an arms race between
the vaccines and the virus
and the next generation of jabs will
need to be smarter
to keep kovid under control
thomas more sky news